19 years ago september 11th happened
baseball's mantra we shall not forget
baseball helped to heal a few things
back then and maybe in 2020 as well on
the mound 27-year-old right-hander eric
fetty 0-1 with an era of 17.36 in three
games and two starts against atlanta
and that's a strike three swing or call
eric fetty gets a k to start his night
swing and a miss on a ball cutting
inside a couple of k's for a
non-strike-out pitcher for the most part
to start his night and it's josh tomlin
who pitched to beauty last time out
against the same washington nationals
that looks like a fair ball it's going
to hit the short corner and with the
ball in front of nick marquez adam eaton
just cruises into second base what is it
about the first inning and extra base
hits for the gnats in this series
monsotto with a walk in two strikeouts
over four against tomlin
off speed soto turns on it
right at the base of the wall eaton
scores here comes trey throw into second
the nats lead to nothing juan soto rbi
total up to 30. once soto can hit off
speed folks
and thames with a base hit
chip hale sending juan soto marcaica's
throw well line
three nothing
nationals
eric thames is now six for eleven career
against josh dominic three balls two
strikes
turner turns on one
that ball's going to hit off the wall
it'll be no contest at second base trey
turner hit number 62
and 25 of them have now gone for extra
bases
juan soto pulled the double first time
drove into
look at him just take it the other way
with a beautiful swing
four nothing gnats juan soto two for two
he's driven in three
just brilliant hitting
and gomes is going to go two for two and
get the nats a two out rbi
five nothing
washington
hey great job of getting on top there by
john gomes
that's a good pitch diving and darting
and eric fetty has his second
consecutive strikeout fourth of the
night
that is golf toward right eaton on the
run won't get it that'll bounce and hit
off the top of the fence nick marcake is
on his way to second with guess what a
double
right off the instep or the left ankle
of ronald lacuna junior and he's down in
a heap that hits solidly and no weight
on the left foot of acuna as he limps
off and will be examined in the braves
locker room another superstar year for
the braves first baseman the 1-1
is right back where it came from a base
hit here comes mark cake is streaking
around third freddie freeman with his
43rd rbi gets the braves on the board
it's a 5-1 game and the atlanta offense
is starting to get on track against
fetty
and that is lying into left field a base
hit will bring home all bees
back-to-back hits it's
5-2 that's more like it freddy stops at
second 38th rbi for ozuna only hold him
down for so long
and him all locked up so fetty gets two
strikeouts into the indy five on the
night but the braves pick up two
and it's a three-run ball game generic
themes will get into bat against the
lefties
and thames will launch one deep to right
center
c
you
later
almost identical
in location to his first nets homer in
atlanta that's his third
and the nats lead six to two peppa is
roasted three balls two strikes
line drive center field that's down for
a hit streaking around his ender and he
will be held up after a good throw from
roblox who's got a cannon for an arm
while zuna's perfect night continues the
bases are loaded with one out i think
that's gonna do it for ryan harper kyle
mcgowan right into some hot water here
facing travis darno
swing and a miss
and that was missing by a wide margin
the value of getting ahead looking for
his first hit of the night he has walked
once the pitch
and ball four a bases loaded walk makes
it six to three charge that run to
harper give swanson his 26th rbi good
patience brings home ender in ciarte
let's see what they can do with ozuna
perfect night three hits and a walk he
has one of atlanta's ribbies
and he shoots this toward right deep
ball eaton turns and looks and that's
going to sail out
ozuna goes opposite field again it's
another homer for atlanta they're 12th
in the last three games and the braves
draw ever closer it's now a 6-4 score
his first four-hit game since september
5th of 2018. we're told
he launches one to left
c
you
later
a three hit night for john gomes
and his third homer of the year puts the
nats back up by three
gomer homer the national league leader
in saves is the dodgers ken lee jansen
with 10. tonight daniel hudson is
seeking number 10. and here's ozuna
tying runs it first
lined into left field that's down for a
base head that'll score two throwback to
second and freddie is safe ozuna singles
drives in two and the braves are down
7-6
3-1
swing and a fly ball hammered toward the
gap that ball is down eaton cuts it off
freddie scores ozona is on his way to
third and the braves have tied it up
redemption indeed for travis darneau the
braves have come all the way back with
three in the ninth to tie it up and this
one's going to the 11th inning first
time we've had an extra in a game go
this far
right side
a couple of crow hops and a throw and
then answer out of the inning after the
braves had bases loaded
michael a taylor and that's a
game-winner
the nats get the bat on the ball and
that will do it in 12.